my favorite superhero team of all time  is the Avengers and I love I love their  battle cry Avengers Assemble  and I was thinking maybe we could put  that battle cry to the test  tonight well and and what what do you  mean okay way we're gonna watch The  Avengers Assemble some IKEA furniture  all right there they are they're  backstage we got Black Widow Captain  America and Thor they are taking  delivery and yes captain  hey Thor has a Blake that's good he's  opening it up that's not yeah it is a  three-piece parva bedroom set and a  Norton coffee table that's right oh no  floors opening the bag don't open for no  understand let's just check in a little  later with them yeah they're on  throughout the show see how they're  doing hey thanks for watching please  subscribe to my youtube channel so they  will stop making me shoot these videos  please